michel thierry atangana vit désormais à
paris du rsa le revenu de solidarité
active et grâce à l'aide de ses soutiens
et réseaux ces avoirs sont toujours gelé
cette situation personnelle
administratives et financières demeurent
bloqués bonjour myrian zain bonjour vous
êtes présidente de l'association
atangana contre l'oppression et
l'arbitraire alors est ce que peut-être
des nouvelles de monsieur atangana
comment va-t-il alors déjà je tiens à
préciser juste qu'ils ne bénéficient pas
du rsa il large et il a refusé il a
refusé parce que bon pour lui c'était
une violence supplémentaire double ont
posé le rsa au lieu de lui proposer la
réhabilitation et le retour de ces
droits
donc il va il se bat il se bat c'est
toujours l'homme résilient que vous avez
découvert dans le documentaire et
comment va-t-il en termes de santé on a
pu lire parfois que dans certains écrits
dans certains reportages dont certains
portraits qu'il avait été torturé qu'en
est il eh bien il souffre des séquelles
de ces tortures
vous avez vu dans le documentaire qu'il
était soigné pour son pied il vous au
brisée dans ce pied
l'un il n'est pas encore stabilisée donc
c'est une souffrance au quotidien pour
ceux dans ses déplacements et
mais sinon il tient il a décidé de se
battre et ce qu'il a retrouvé sa famille
il a retrouvé sa famille mais une
absence de 17 ans ça ça compte
oui ça laisse des séquelles j'imagine
alors justement où est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
en est sa situation personnelle
administratif je disais ses avoirs sont
bloqués et ont donc une plainte qui a
été déposée par ses avocats contre x
pour séquestration
au vu des dix sept ans passés en prison
cameroun mais cette réhabilitation ce
dégel des avoirs il n'y a que le
cameroun finalement qui peut l'effectuer
et pourquoi pas la france puisqu'il y à
une décision de plus il y à un décret de
remise de près de peine qui date de 2014
on peut très bien des jeux laisser avoir
lever les scellés et rien n'est fait
tout pour vous c'est quoi c'est une
décision en fait du cameroun qui a été
appliquée en france c'est quoi la france
est complice
non je ne dirais pas ça comme ça là il
est victime donc de cette décision au
cameroun la france a suivi
maintenant il suffit simplement
d'appliquer la ville de nu est ce que
vous diriez à l'image de ce qu'on a pu
découvrir dans ce film qui accuse la
france d'un silence presque
assourdissant sur le cas de michel
thierry atangana que finalement on est
encore dans cette idée et qu'il n'est
pas soutenue par la france
on a quelques avancées le ministre des
affaires étrangères le drian a reconnu
la vie du groupe de travail sur la
détention arbitraire il faut que ça se
traduise au niveau de l'administration
et au niveau des instances mais on a une
avancée au niveau français pour ça va
doucement doucement
là on compte un petit peu sur la
protection diplomatique parce qu'avec
une absence de protection consulaire
pendant 13 ans là il ya clairement des
manquements de la france qu'il faut
corriger
et c'est une situation exceptionnelle
très grave et qui nécessitent une
intervention au plus haut niveau
est-ce que vous avez justement vous le
disiez jean yves le drian a fait des
parrains vous avez été reçu il a été
reçu peut-être par le ministère des
affaires étrangères par la cellule
diplomatique de l'elysée est ce qu'on
connaît sa situation aujourd'hui
il a été reçu et en 2014 est depuis en
catimini
on a fait des promesses des promesses
non tenues le président hollande a été
courageux dans cette affaire parce que à
peine arrivée à l'elysée il s'est
mobilisé pour la libération de michel
thierry atangana le travail reste
inachevée parce que il a été libéré mais
c'est difficile pour lui de se réinsérer
donc je ne veux pas dire qu'il a été
clochardisé par la suite mais cette non
réponse est quand même violente
est ce que le titre de ce film c'est un
scandale d'état
est ce que vous y verriez que en
scandale d'état au pluriel est ce qu'il
a été abandonné par la france sachant
que je les a pris il est exclusivement
français oui il a été complètement
abandonné par la france pendant des
années des années alors que le les
américains donc c'est le département
d'état américain s'est inquiété de sa
situation depuis 1999 je le rappelle
qu'il a été annoncé en politique par les
états unis
il a été sa détention a été reconnu
comme étant arbitraire par le
département d'état est selon vous la
france est restée silencieuse
il ya eu plusieurs excuses par exemple
lorsque les ministères dès le le
ministère des affaires étrangères le
quai d'orsay a été sollicité à plusieurs
reprises à chaque fois qu'il ya eu un
changement de gouvernement
la réponse était notre compatriote est
quand même franco camerounais au
cameroun elecam n'est donc pas
d'ingérence
on n'intervient pas mais est-il
camerounais les français d'origine
camerounaise et il est français depuis
1988 il entre au cameroun avec un titre
de séjour un permis durant la guerre du
ca nationalité camerounaise absolu ce
cas vous dites on ne peut pas avoir de
nouvelles nationalités quand on est
comme maintenant il ouvre la claire
michel thierry atangana et français il a
perdu sa nationalité camerounaise
sauf qu'on a continué de le considérer
comme étant camerounais c'est à dessein
à dessein alors dernière question
pourquoi est ce que vous vous avez
décidé de vous engager dans ce dossier
je me suis engagé j'ai rencontré michel
thierry atangana un peu par hasard il
était question de sa réinsertion
administratives et puis j'ai découvert
un dossier et en même temps que le
dossier j'ai j'ai rencontré
la violence de l'indifférence certains
défenseurs des droits de l'homme qui
vous disent n'y a pas de fumée sans fin
sans feu et un racisme social parce
qu'il est financier il est homme jeune
financier veut donc les questions
d'argent en france on aime ça en gros il
est forcément un peu responsable c'est
ça que vous voulez dire oui et puis la
france l'afrique les sous qu'il est
d'origine africaine bon ça sent pas bon
je sais c'est pas le sait pas le propos
c'est pas le sujet et donc j'ai décidé
de m'engager dans ce combat parce que il
y avait cette injustice et cette
violence et cette indifférence
bon bah écoutez merci en attendant
d'être venu témoigner sur ce combat
myriam jeune maman reçu merci beaucoup
alors la sphère michel thierry atangana
est elle un scandale d'état et pourquoi
ce cas est-il symbolique des relations
entre la france ancienne puissance
coloniale et ses anciennes colonies
que dire par ailleurs de ses relations
la françafrique est elle morte ou est-ce
que son dernier vestige est le franc cfa
une monnaie africaine indexés sur l'euro
pour en débattre j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir antoine blazer bonjour vous
êtes journaliste et écrivain vous êtes
spécialiste du continent africain vous
avez signé africa france quand les
dirigeants africains deviennent les
maîtres du jeu
réédité en poche dans la collection
pluriel de fayard 7 et en 2017
william bourdon bienvenus vous n'êtes
qu'à président de la plate forme de
protection des lanceurs d'alerté
d'afrique président fondateur de
l'association sherpa
pierre jacquemot vous êtes chercheur
associé à l'iris vous êtes présidente de
l'ot angie great professionnels du
développement solidaire et vous êtes
ancien ambassadeur de france dans
plusieurs pays d'afrique kenya ghana ou
république démocratique du congo
bienvenue à vous enfin laurent bigot
vous êtes consultant indépendant
spécialiste également du continent
africain vous êtes ancien diplomate
responsable afrique de l'ouest au quai
d'orsay
bienvenue alors peut-être un mot sur la
sphère michel thierry atangana est ce
que vous diriez comme est sous titré ce
documentaire que c'est un scandale
d'état
william bourdon d'abord moi je vais très
fort avec vous mon cher que jamais de
réponse que j'étais l'avocat de michel
des années donc je les accompagne et
donc ça me met pas dans une position
sinon idéale pour pour répondre enfin
quand même j'ai laissé de répondre
cet homme à juste titre s'est sentis
abandonnés par la france et à juste
titre a considéré qu'il y avait du côté
des services consulaires de résine forme
de résine ya les venir une forme de
résignation à sa situation qu'on
essayait d'objectiver peut-être dans un
désir des lignes de nationalité mais oui
quelque chose qui ressemble à un refus
de prendre en compte sa qualité de
citoyen français qui est évidemment
créateur d'obligations et comme vous
voulez pas les tenir on a fait cette
pirouette qui était d'une certaine façon
de le déchoir defacto de sa nationalité
française
et tout ça pourquoi parce que évidemment
le sous jacent c'est cette frilosité
cette timidité cette complaisance qui
existent parfois de façon très cynique
ou pas d'ailleurs avec certains grands
patrons africains et dans l'espace paul
biya pierre jacquemot pourquoi ce
silence coupable de la france durant 13
années peut-être je ne sais pas j'ai pas
personnellement suivi le suivi le
dossier est incontestablement fin je
tuerai dire quand même en tant qu ancien
diplomate
les services consulaires font en général
du mieux qu'ils peuvent poursuivre les
et la situation des compatriotes en
prison assure des visites régulières et
puis se préoccupent de leur sort et
éventuellement apporte une aide
matérielle aux familles lorsque celles
ci sont dans le besoin c'est une une
règle absolue dans le cas d'espèce que
je ne connais pas dans l'est dans les
détails mais j'entends ce que dit
william bourdon
il ya eu probablement des manquements
c'est possible mais je me
je ne souhaite pas commenter n'ayant pas
de sympathie particulière
antoine glaser est ce que vous aviez eu
vent de cette affaire déjà oui
absolument mais c'etait un
malheureusement parmi d'autres et c'est
vrai que ce qui a vraiment changé c'est
qu'à lui à l'ambassadeur de france qui a
été très court une autre qui n'étaient
plus reçus par le président paul biya
paul biya a été traité par la france
encore maintenant comme de la
nitroglycérine à partir du moment où
c'est un pays où vous avez surtout une
sécurité israéliennes où la france se
sent pas chez elle au cameroun comme
elle peut souvent se sentir à tord en
côte d'ivoire au sénégal en genre de
pays c'est vrai que cameroun personne
biya a toujours été traité différemment
comme s'ils avaient craignait vraiment
paul biya craignaient ses réactions
et du coup c'est vraiment un pays où
c'est motus bouche cousue c'est vrai
voruz t1 c'est particulier au cameroun
et franchement bruno gazeau c'est
étonnant je veux dire c'est parce que
j'ai jamais vu un ambassadeur de france
je veux pas citer son nom mais vous avez
un ancien ambassadeur de france qui le
conseillait actuellement de paul biya
depuis des années les années qu'à son
bureau au palais d etoudi à yaoundé
laurent bigot quand on entend la
l'analyse de monsieur les verts diriez
vous que il ya eu des intérêts
supérieur à celui du ressortissant
français qu'est michel thierry atangana
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il n'a pas
bénéficié de la protection consulaire
que tout citoyen français est en droit
de bénéficier dans une telle
circonstance sans préjuger de la delà du
fait que la procédure était étonné ou
pas était légitime et ça c est clair
donc on suppose que derrière il ya eu
des arbitrages effectivement il n'était
pas dans les intérêts français de de lui
assurer sa protection consulaire
c'est vrai que c'est une croyance la
pratique j'ai ok danser il ya une
croyance qui consiste à dire il faut pas
froisser tel chef d'état si on veut
obtenir d'autres choses par ailleurs moi
j'ai toujours pensé qu'on pouvait tout
obtenir à partir du moment considéré que
c'était nos intérêts mais c'est vrai que
cette croyance elle est tenace et
souvent on fait des arbitrages alors
qu'on peut avoir les deux
je sais la pratique que j'ai eues en
diplomatie et on peut légitimement
penser que dans le cas d'espèce il ya eu
des arbitrages alors la question de ces
arbitrages elle pose la question aussi
de la place de la france en afrique
on se souvient donc d'un discours d'
emmanuel macron à ouagadougou au burkina
faso en novembre dernier devant les
étudiants il déclaré à l'époque qu'il
n'y a plus de politique africaine de la
france
alors quelles sont justement aujourd'hui
les relations entre les deux pays on
écoute le président français mais les
idées
[Applaudissements]
alors ce passage a été largement
commentée donc il est face aux étudiants
à ouagadougou il vient de déclarer en
préambule donc enfin au début de son
discours qu'il n'y a plus de politique
africaine de la france et malgré donc le
côté anecdotique de cette histoire
d'aller réparer la climatisation
qu'est-ce qu'il faut voir en fait dans
ce dense dans le message qui est envoyé
ici aux étudiants ouagadougou bien
jacques mans il ya plus de politique
africaine mais à une politique française
en afrique
je crois que c'est comme ça qu'il faut
l'interpréter d'ailleurs ça a été redit
par l'un de ses conseillers
quelques temps après ça veut peut-être
dire que il ya plus de focales comme sur
l'ancien pré carré
mais une ouverture d'ailleurs manuel
macron va se rendre aux nigériens il a
une ouverture sur le kényan sur d'autres
régions qui ne sont pas dans le dans le
giron traditionnel de centre d'une
nouvelle politique
nous votons pas là il intègre aussi
dedans l'afrique ce qui est pas toujours
été le cas les pays du maghreb pour lui
c'est la grande afrique 54 55 pays
donc je pense que c'est un peu ça que ça
veut dire il dit aussi une sauce qui est
intéressant dans le discours de
ouagadougou
je suis d'une génération qui il l'a dit
au moins cinq fois cette formule face
début de cette phrase qui n'a pas connu
de l'histoire coloniale qui n'a pas été
impliqué dans ce dossier cela dont je
il veut se placer compte tenu de son âge
et de l'auditoire qu'il avait à
ouagadougou c'est là des étudiants dans
une place territoire quand tu ne vois là
dans une île et sur un registre
générationnel ce qui lui permet de
parler de start up lyonnaise de pme etc
il veut sortir absolument du bourbier
ceci étant c'est pas le premier kit et
knock
une force dont l'attitude dans la
relation avec l'afrique
nicolas sarkozy avait le premier dit on
sort de la françafrique ça a été redit
par hollande
certains ministres étaient même un peu
plus loin ça leur a coûté cher comme
bockel par exemple puis qui se sont fait
rattraper par la suite mais devra donc à
mon avis c'est ça que ça veut dire il ya
une politique française en afrique comme
une politique française
et on peut le consistoire lecture
française en train de les airs il faut
il faut quand même il faut se dire que
même macron arrive à un moment où
l'afrique est mondialisée si on démarre
pas là dessus on comprend pas à quel
point la françafrique est totalement
anachronique il afrique et mondialisée
vous aviez des bastions français comme
djibouti sont les chinois il ya quelques
semaines sont les russes qui se sont
installés en centrafrique
donc on et laurine afrique mondialisée
emmanuel macron d'ansac réelle politique
est également diplomatie économique et
qui s'adresse aux premiers de cordée en
afrique comme il s'adresse au premier
corner en france s'adresse évidemment
aux pays qui vont compter donc
effectivement il va rival et au nigeria
il a reçu et joão lourenço le président
angolais
donc il est dans un autre truc il y a la
seule chose que moi je trouve qu'il ya
en moins pour l'instant c'est le
paternalisme ça veut dire vous c'est
vous nous c nous on n'a pas parlé devant
des chefs d'état africains il démarre
même si c'est une partie de démago
devant devant la jeunesse africaine mais
yahia les deux chérubins malade oui mais
c'est aussi de dire vous c'est vous
naissez nous il va même si on relit le
discours il dit à un moment donné à la
jeunesse africaine c'est pas moi qui
vais virer vos autocrate démerdez vous
faites comme vous vos copains de du
burkina faso fait votre évolution ne
vais pas faire la révolution à votre
place donc le vrai changement il vient
pas de la france le vrai changement il y
en afrique
c'est cette afrique mondialisé qui
oblige la france a changé même si il
était rétro emmanuel macron il
existerait pire en afrique
william bourdon que dire justement de la
position française en afrique est ce que
vraiment on a lâché on a largué les
amarres évident qu'on a pas largué les
amarres il suffit pas de quelques
pirouettes sémantiques de quelques
gestes symboliques si sympathique soit
il comme eux on va restituer le
l'art primitif africain balle à qui je
pense que dsk était effectivement une
annonce m
on va d classifiés secret défense des
archives sur son caractère adoma sankara
qu'était l'ancien usage du symbole c'est
ce qu'on attend aussi les politiques
mais le symbole ne suffit pas dans la
durée
d'abord il ya un très grand passif sur
l'image de la france qui n'a cessé de se
dégrader en afrique - portez témoignage
les raisons sont très complexes on n'a
pas le temps mais cette image s'est
profondément dégradée y compris chez les
jeunes générations
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que notre
jeune président a compris qu'il fallait
cibler au delà de cette espèce de
rupture générationnelle dont il a fait
le symbole d'une note et de modernité
extraordinaire
il fallait cibler les nouvelles
générations moi ce que je vois très très
très modestement c'est que évidemment
qu'on n'est plus dans la caricature de
la politique africaine le cabinet noir
foca depuis diplomatie parallèle
bouleverser le paysage la relation
france afrique c'est la menace
terroriste et c'est
l'instrumentalisation des menaces
terroristes comme une rente par assa
retombe de kleptocrates de despote pour
demander et obtenir le silence
complaisant et coupable de la france ce
que rose et xavier mbia - dont pour être
là c'est que vous avez des dirigeants
qui s'arrogent en fait le statut d' je
suis dernièrement fois roy qui font
croire qu'ils sont le bouclier absolu de
la lutte contre un risque qui parfois
peuvent l'être mais qui vaut 6 manipule
cette menace agite aussi eu le chiffon
rouge d'une absence de coopération si
demain il y avait les otages français
sa pole bien l'utilisent très bien aussi
pour répondre à ce que disait antoine il
ya quelques instants et donc ça veut
dire que c'est comme ça c'est difficile
ça veut dire que une partie aujourd'hui
la politique en afrique qu'en afrique où
la politique africaine est fait
élaboré par les services de sécurité
français cet impôt sur les services de
sécurité qui aujourd'hui sont les
instruments d'une métamorphose de la
françafrique c'est à dire qui en fait
sont les acteurs d'une diplomatie
parallèle
laurent bigot la politique africaine de
la france c'est quoi c'est donc une
politique sécuritaire pour reprendre les
propos de william bourdon s'est
heureusement c'est très clair c'est que
le seul budget qui augmente
en afrique c'est le budget lié à la
sécurité puisque tous les autres budgets
subissent des coupes sont moins la
coopération le ciel tout le réseau
diplomatique le réseau culturel
si vous regardez sur les dix dernières
années c'est assez divisés par deux sens
sans aucun problème donc c'était évident
on est guidé complètement par la menace
terroriste par nos peurs c'est à dire
que notre politique africaine est
d'abord guidé par nos peurs mais
revenons à l'extrait que vous avez
diffusé des manuels macro s'amuse de la
question qu'on lui pose sur la
climatisation
quel manque d'empathie quel manque
d'empathie
vous avez un étudiant qui parle de sa
réalité son vrai problème à lui c'est
qu'il ne peut pas étudier dans des
conditions décentes et il exprime au
président français et qu'est ce qu'il a
en retour il a une attitude presque
goguenarde l'air de dire mais moi je
suis pas le président du burkina faso et
pourquoi cet étudiant s'adresse au
président français il est tellement
désespérés ils ne croient plus que sa
situation peut s'améliorer qu'en dernier
recours il s'adresse au président
français et la réponse qu'on a c'est que
moi que j'interprète comme du mépris que
je ressens comme du mépris
on ne rigole pas avec ça passe quand on
connaît les conditions d'études à
l'université ouaga ça n'est pas drôle
effectivement ils ont eu la clim le
temps du voyage d'à emmanuel macron il
n'avait pas avant ils n'ont pas eu après
après sur la politique africaine qu'est
ce qui change ce qui change pas moi je
vous dis franchement pas grand chose qui
a changé j'avais fait un papier sur le
discours qu emmanuel macron a fait ouaga
il ya énormément de thématiques bord des
phrases qui reprenait le discours de
françois hollande à dakar
quand j'entends emmanuel macron qui dit
devant mamadou issoufou vous êtes à un
modèle de démocratie
j'aimerais bien savoir quelle est la
définition de la démocratie parce que
mamadou issoufou a été réélu alors que
son principal adversaire était en prison
a fait campagne depuis la prison il a
été réélu avec 92% des voix qui est
dizaine d'activistes de société civile
qui sont en prison depuis plusieurs mois
sans aucun procès sens
c'est ça la réalité donc dit vous êtes
un exemple de démocratie bayrou ça me
rappelle vraiment ce qui s'est fait
depuis 15 ans y a pas tellement de
rupture et puis on dit c'est la fin de
la françafrique d'abord il l'a jamais
proclamé emmanuel macron c'est à la fin
de la françafrique trouvez moi un
discours il le dit qu'un appât d'ascq
avait été tellement dit que c'était des
blanches et deuxièmement la françafrique
c'est quoi c'est la confusion des genres
entre les affaires et la politique oui
elle conseil présidentiel pour l'afrique
c'est quoi c'est pas la confusion des
genres entre la politique et les
affaires vous avez des hommes et des
femmes d'affaires qui sont un conseil
présidentiel pour l'afrique est quand
même en la présidentielle et dont
certains ont des activités business en
afrique c'est toujours très difficile de
faire comprendre qu'est ce que c'était
que la france a pris 2 hir 160 jusqu'à
la chute du mur de berlin en 90 ou
c'était la fin de sa fille d'état et
maintenant vous avez effectivement une
françafrique de réseaux privés
quand vous avez un certain non mais je
dis pas ça pour laurent bigot mais deux
diplomates français
deux militaires français des dizaines de
milliers de types c'est hallucinant qui
sont qui sont qui sont au service de
chefs d'état africains dans des réseaux
n'influence en france c'est ça aussi
l'africa france hélas cette françafrique
là on est plus dans la françafrique
d'état de de gaulle de papa foccart etc
on est dans un autre domaine mais encore
une fois est-ce à dire d'abord pour
reprendre votre votre idée d'africa
france ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui le
syndrome et renverser le paradigme est
renversée et que c'est l'afrique en fête
qui a eu une influence sur la vie j'ai
des copains se tient la semaine dernière
j'ai vu à paris rentré de moscou il faut
il faut qu'on sorte aussi faut qu'on se
rend compte de cette afrique mondialisée
jeudi à mâcon on a une vision de
l'afrique aujourd'hui qu'est celle les
années 40 un bar de françafrique et même
des militaires français
sait on est il ya 54 pays en afrique 1
giga quand emmanuel macron il va aller
au nigeria quand il reçoit joie ou leur
en dessous de l'angola cc on est bon
même si l angolagate ya des histoires
entre la france et l'angola
mais on est quand même dans une autre
période historique
pierre jacquemot et william bourdon oui
je vais quand même faire une précision
le civisme c'est une donnée que l'on
rencontre toutes les diplomaties quelle
qu'elle soit c'est pas une particularité
française
les français ne sont pas devenus à une
pétition signée avant de rentrer dans ma
carrière se rencontrer et tes collègues
ambassadeur d'autres pays qui était tout
aussi civique que ce que vous dénoncez
je dois apporter une précision
historique importante
vous évoquez un indice koke lieu le 28
novembre mais vous n'évoquez pas ce qui
s'est passé deux heures après accra et
c'est ça à mon avis qui est beaucoup
plus intéressant pour illustrer propos
d'antoine à savoir la perception que les
africains ont en l'occurrence de la
france n'est plus la même le président
du ghana fraîchement élu nana akufo addo
une personnalité très importante
ancien avocat à paris francophone donc
très à l'aise dans ce type de relation
fasse un seul de l'état a improvisé un
discours où il a dit très clairement en
anglais nous n'avons pas besoin des deux
et ça ça a véritablement je dirais scier
les jambes du du président français qui
ne s'y attendait absolument pas et ça se
voit en body l'un voilà c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant qu'il sort de la clim
mais à mon avis la véritable leçon c'est
s'est passé 48 heures après c'est quand
un à-coup fois dit on veut un mode de
relation qui soit basée sur l'intérêt
mutuel et non pas sur une une assistance
d'ailleurs les mots sont tous très
péjoratif aide assistance et
condescendance et unilatérale etc c'est
ce que des gens comme nana akufo addo de
cette nouvelle je dirais pas une
nouvelle génération parce qu'il a 70 ans
passés mais ces chefs d'état qui ne sont
pas dans cette relation ancienne avec la
france et qui avait un type de relation
très émancipés avec l'ancienne puissance
coloniale en l'occurrence c'est
britannique
il peut il peut le dire il a
parfaitement raison et c'est ça mon avis
qu'ils peuvent cliquer qui est tout à
fait nouveau c'est qu'on est sur un
autre terrain que les chances mutuel et
l'intérêt mutuel serait relations
diplomatiques qu'ils sont d'égal à égal
il y avait le rapport de jacques attali
sur la francophonie souvenez vous il ya
deux ans et qui disait c'est une chance
formidable pour la france pour l'europe
mais aussi pour l'afrique de puiser dans
cette espèce d atouts formidables qui
est cette culture commune partagée on en
est très loin il avait deux
recommandations qui était un vieux
l'accord avec s'inquiéter
extrêmement pertinentes et juste tout ça
était totalement vendanger et le
résultat aujourd'hui c'est que une
partie des grands acteurs nouveau
moderne courageuse cette société civile
africaine qui émerge quand même ici ou
là avec audace qu'on n'entend pas assez
se détournent de la france vont vers le
canada vont vers des pays où ils se
détournent en raison de ses
atermoiements il vous avez raison de
dire que évidemment le cynisme et une
vertus très partagés mais en tous les
cas elle est proportionnelle aussi au
caractère asymétrique de la relation or
c'est le caractère asymétrique dans la
relation avec l'afrique qui fait que
parfois on bascule vers l'hyper cynisme
dernière idée il ya la menace terroriste
qui est manipulé pour organiser la
pérennité et l'impunité parfois de
d'espèces de kleptocrates et avec un
silence radio
quand même parfois assourdissant c'était
vous la déclaration françois hollande
qui dit mais je comprends bien que
monsieur sassou n'guesso face à un
référendum pour asseoir de troisième
quatrième mandat
cette déclaration était absolument
scandaleuse alors macro sans doute plus
habile il se gardera de de propos aussi
complaisant la menace migratoire
le spectacle peuvent nous donnons dans
le traitement de la crise migratoire
alors bien sûr michel rocard avait
regretté cette phrase on peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde bien
il devrait en prendre notre de bijoux de
mélodies est exact que la france est
toujours le traitement des migrants la
croix rouge la montée des populistes
faut bien comprendre que chez
rassure-t-on d'afrique à cette espèce
d'idée que la france avait un devoir
d'aucuns disent et un destin manifeste
d'être quand même le pays le plus
exigeant sur les principes d'hospitalité
et de fraternité
aujourd'hui cette image là est
complètement train de se détruire alors
justement là-dessus le continent
africain
c'est quand même une terre de départ
aussi un et on le voit justement avec
l'aquarius on voit à quel point donc les
routes de l'immigration qui arrive en
libye font enfin deviennent de d'une
partie de l'afrique subsaharienne
la france a souhaité donc augmenter
l'aide au développement mais
potentiellement aussi la conditionner à
la gestion des flux migratoires voire à
créer des hotspots donc des centres de
tri directement en afrique
est ce que c'est ça aussi
un poteau potentiellement pierre
jacquemot la politique africaine de la
france alors associé aide et migration
est absurde ça même des effets
contraires si vous aussi vous
d'augmenter le niveau de formation
professionnelle de jeunes africains ça
les pousse naturellement la migration
c'est absurde parce que la mobilité
c'est un élément fondamental du
développement dans toutes les sociétés
la mobi kids la possibilité d'aller voir
ailleurs et de revenir est un élément
est un élément d'enrichissement
absolument fondamental c'est absurde
parce que la migration est d'abord intra
africaines concerne les pays africains
entre la migration à 90% à 91 et les ti
story que tu te fais dire les sociétés
africaines migrent jusqu'au cap pour
ceux qui font ça les congolais à abidjan
pour ce qui concerne les burkinabés et
c'est donc c'est une donnée fondamentale
limitée et d'associer l'aide ce qui
effectivement pour ça renvoie aux peurs
que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure que mon
collègue évoqué tout à l'heure ça
renvoie aux peurs le silence ce
déferlement migrants à la recelle
verrouillé c'est complètement absurde
mais ça veut dire que quoi cet
engagement sur l'aide au développement
c'est un engagement de façade là aussi
on et l'endurance
on peut alors bon il ya un engagement
qui pour l'instant est purement qui a
purement théorique
la france est très en retard par rapport
à ses voisins britanniques ou allemands
en terme de niveau dette publique la
france fait essentiellement du prêt très
peu de dons la france a un système
totalement centralisée qui fait peu
appel aux associations aux collectivités
locales et aux opérateurs de terrain
très peu 1 3 4% contre 15 20% et d'autre
donc on a un système qui est kiss me
rappela que on a une liste de 17 pays
prioritaires dans les flux dead qu'on
donne chaque année il n'y a pas un seul
de ces 17 pays prioritaires qui fermait
qu'il qui est parmi les dix
bénéficiaires donc il ya je veux dire on
a un discours d'un côté et une
orgueilleuse nokia système qui marche
sur la tête qu'on a dénoncé face parle
de nous c'est les ong françaises qui
marche sur la tête qui ne part
absolument pas des considérations de
terrain tu as des préoccupations des
bénéficiaires ont dit
lutter contre la pauvreté on s'adresse
pas aux pauvres et aux conditions de vie
on n'analyse pas la situation des femmes
les préoccupations de la jeunesse
secteur on monte un truc entre le quai
d'orsay bercy veut et l'afd qu'on fait
valider à washington mais qui n'arrive
jamais au destinataire fils y arrive au
destinataire mais dans des montants aa
signifiant et qui de toute façon il n'ya
pas de redevabilité de la part des
bénéfices sur l'efficacité de ce
dispositif
c'est un peu ça qui est promu lui aussi
à ouagadougou par les étudiants dans
leurs relations avec le président on a
des débats sans fin sur l'aide comment
faut-il faire mieux pas mieux plus pas
plus mais la réalité c'est que personne
ne se pose la question de quand est ce
qu'on va arrêter l'aide
l'ambition de l'aide c'est que ça
s'arrête et cette question n'est jamais
posée c'est à dire que l'iapv alors que
ça s'arrête sinon c'est à dire que ça ne
fonctionne pas et ça fait cinquante ans
que ça ne fonctionne pas il faut pas se
raconter d'histoires oui les cimetières
ces civils viennent nous dire que si ça
arrive pas au destinataire et si ça ne
répond pas au besoin forcément ça ne
peut pas fonctionner donc de la question
c'est quand est ce qu'on va l'arrêter
moi j'ai un ami ivoirien qui me dit le
led c'est comme l'allaitement il ya un
moment faut que ça s'arrête sinon c'est
malsain
ben oui j ils sont les premiers donc
après vous avez créé des habitudes et
des relations avec certaines élites
africaines qui utilisent cette aide pour
eux se maintenir au pouvoir et alimenter
leur propre survie politique
mais au final ça n'arrive pas du tout
aux destinataires et on est dans un dans
un jeu de dupes que tout le monde dont
tout le monde a conscience parce que
vous avez les discours officiels et puis
ce qui se dit dans les couloirs des
grandes institutions de bretton-woods
est là pour le coup le cynisme c'est
avec un grand c parce qu'il faut on
entend des choses oui on sait ça sert à
rien mais il faut le faire
discours comme ça qu'on entend c'est
qu'il ya un cynisme terrible des grandes
organisations internationales sur le
fait que l'aide n'est pas utile et qu'on
ne pose pas les vraies questions et
qu'on n'a pas le courage de dire mais
d'ailleurs pourquoi aidons-nous
l'afrique
peut-être parce que hélas je viendrai
c'est william bourdon à un moment il va
falloir faire plier
certains pays africains pour accueillir
des hotspots pour gérer les flux
migratoires et déléguer la gestion de
ces flux
est ce que on en passe par l'aide au
développement tout le monde rêve comme
le rovio qu'un jour l'afrique n'ait plus
besoin d'être évidemment que ce rêve au
partage tous ça voudrait dire à ce
moment là il se veut été retrouvé sauf
qu'on allait très loin si on coupe le
circuit de l'est d'aujourd'hui ça
provoquera des catastrophes musulmans
tellurique enchaîné autant de bombes
retardement donc c était la vraie
question je suis pas spécialiste de
l'aide c'est évidemment une
restructuration en redéploiement au delà
des soins de vue il y aurait beaucoup à
dire on n'a pas le temps sur la
politique de la sd en afrique rejet très
riche faraoni major de dtn est très très
riche des milliards des milliards et
avec le sentiment d'une partie de cette
société civile africaine qu'il ya tout
eu des micro projets de pme tout à fait
admirable et qui ont des effets vertueux
dans la durée qui sont négligés parce
qu'on privilégie des projets à haute
valeur ajoutée politique ou publics
antoine désert par la difficulté
effectivement c'est d'abord de
responsabiliser d'aider des autocrates
qui pompent déjà toute une partie des
ressources du pays
donc vous pomper une partie des
ressources de pays puisse vous demander
de l'aide
il ad c'est déjà un premier problème
même dans le domaine de la santé avec un
somme de choses du côté français vous
avez maintenant le quai d'orsay
d'ailleurs qui qui pleure parce qu'ils
n'ont plus que cinq ou six milliards de
budget alors que l' agence française de
développement
10 14 milliards d'euros c'est absolument
énorme et c'est vrai que ce comme la
certain nombre d'entreprises françaises
sont en perdition en afrique par rapport
à la concurrence on parle toujours de
chine brésil inde mais on oublie les
turcs on oublie des partenaires
allemands
qu'est-ce qui se passe une partie de
l'aide finalement de la france des
annulations de dettes
ils sont intégrés très souvent dans la
partie et de développement en fait ça
sert à un peu à soutenir les entreprises
françaises
on a recommencé leydier en disant aux
chefs d'état auquel vous un nul 2 2
milliards d'euros à la côte d'ivoire et
montant astronomique avait alassane
ouattara mais en échange là pour tel et
tel pot ça serait bien que ce soit elle
est l entreprise qui s'est passé pour je
ne sais quel métro c'est bien mais à
temps mais c'est du 10 et du faux pas
s'il faut pas se leurrer les grands
projets que la fente affaires au sénégal
le train ou en côte d'ivoire pour les
ponts et au tout ce qui est
infrastructure c'est le contribuable
français qui va payer
qui peut et qui peut imaginer autre
chose mais en même temps la rente dans
ces pays quand vous êtes premier
producteur de cacao
quand vous êtes dans les visuels dans le
premier camp que vous ayez le pétrole
tentera d'augmenter de tous les pays
d'afrique centrale est il
à voir à nouveau la manne il ya aucune
redistribution
donc c'est vrai que laurent bigot a
raison le problème de l'aide se pose
réellement au bout d'un moment si vous
voulez sur une longue période
il ya c'est vrai que il ya une la sq a
vraiment nouveau c'est les sociétés
civiles africaines et les ong locales
qui elles qui ce regret de ne pas avoir
aussi aussi un petit peu même des
retombées de tout c'est elle qui est
donnée à des grands en dépit simple et
puissante ong occidentales pierre
jacquemot rapide oui ce sera un peu
nuancer le propos d'antoine laser pas
mettre toutes les entreprises françaises
dans le même pays qui les associer à la
françafrique la zone euro contre la
vitrine avant la ville et des milliers
d'autres sont conscientes 16 notamment
de taille moyenne qui est intégré dans
sa tombe de secteur
concurremment avec d'autres et qui
respecte les règles du marché sur les
appels d'offres etc l'état et certaines
d'entre elles d'ailleurs portent des
projets de responsabilité sociétale et
environnementale qui sont très très très
intéressant et respectant
l'environnement
on est son travail le travail décembre
l'autre chose qui est très importante et
je pense que c'est une des leçons de
cette discussion c'est la montée des
sociétés civiles africaines
on ne fait plus n'importe quoi en
afrique en tout cas sur l'afrique de
l'ouest sur l'afrique de l'est le kenya
où seul afrique du sud il y à des
interlocuteurs qui sont des contrepoids
très très important quand une attitude
d'observation d'alert sur les mauvais
comportements et un certain nombre
d'individus qui sont encore en afrique
centrale peux pas les citer mais au
cameroun au congo au congo kinshasa en
guinée équatoriale où des familles qui
se sont installées au pouvoir depuis 50
ans que ce soit au togo ou au gabon ils
ont du souci à se faire dans l'est dans
les prochaines années du fait
précisément comme fait pas n'importe
quoi
probablement ils vont imposer de
l'intérieur veut que les rentes
s'amenuiser quand les rentes
s'amenuisent
le partage du gâteau devient de plus en
plus difficile et c'est là où seraient
que des bébés des conflits de famille ou
des conflits d'alliances mais
je pense que le c'est très important
d'avoir cette observation dynamique
sociétale qui qui ont incarné d'ailleurs
des changements fabi l'eau au début des
années 2000 dit ça soit le bas les
citoyens à ouagadougou il y en a marre à
dakar pour prendre ces de ces deux cas
d'autres militants que vous que vous
soutenez moi qui le connais en
particulier en république démocratique
du congo ce temps la situation
extrêmement grave
mais avec un courage absolument
admirable admirable et je pense que
c'est ça la donne nouvelle et qui fait
qu'on ne pourra plus faire n'importe
quoi en afrique
alors il ya un débat rapidement qui
agite les opinions africaines depuis
quelques années un débat qui s'efforcent
peu à peu à peu par don en europe c'est
la question du franc cfa cette monnaie
donc héritage de la période coloniale
est toujours en circulation dans la zone
franc un anachronisme que beaucoup de
chercheurs ou d'économistes cherche à
effacer emmanuel macron a été interpellé
toujours avoir des doutes par un
étudiant on écoute j'ai prédit il
le français va la france elles
nourrissent pas le mettre l emmener le
chaos qu'est ce que ça veut dire
j'avais d'abord c'est un choix des états
membres deuxième secteur
personne n'oblige quelques étapes pour
ce soit en informant le président
aimerait t il demain je ne suis plus
dans la zone
il est plus laurent ni goisque vraiment
si le président décide de sortir de la
zone franc du franc cfa il n'y est plus
est ce que on est arrivé au bout d'un
cycle
techniquement oui mais ça se prépare
mais le sujet de la monnaie c'est la
monnaie ça dépend ce que vous en faites
c'est quelle politique monétaire vous
avez comme toutes les monnaies le franc
cfa des avantages et des inconvénients
incontestablement tous les fantasmes
liés à l'histoire du franc cfa il faut
les balayer parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
ça n'est plus d'actualité comme l'y
antoine glaser le monde a changé et
franchement est là et l'afrique commerce
avec bien d'autres zones que le que la
france et l'europe
mais la réalité c'est qu'est ce que vous
faites de votre monique et moi je
m'adresse aux chefs d'état africains
judicaire qu'est ce que vous avez fait
des avantages du franc cfa et qu'est ce
que vous faites pour minérais minorer
les inconvénients
ça s'appelle une politique monétaire et
politique monétaire encore faut-il avoir
sa propre monnaie mais ils sont c'est
lui qui décide
elle est quand même indexés sur l'euro
cette monnaie est alors c'est une force
bon c'est une ségolène c'est une force à
quel niveau parce que les apporter sa
garantie une inflation très basse
donc c'est un avantage quand vous faites
de la politique monétaire nous fait des
arbitrages entre différents paramètres
c'est ça la politique monétaire donc il
faut choisir et une nouvelle fois le
franc cfa arrimé à l'euro à des
avantages à des inconvénients quelles
sont les politiques monétaires des états
africains
si ces états africains ne peuvent pas
conduire les politiques monétaires qui
le souhaitent alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont
comme alternative et en quoi ils
travaillent sur ces alternatives
voilà les vraies questions les débats
passionnés qui renvoie il ya quarante
enfin le monde a changé
les fantasmes qui sont véhiculés que le
franc cfa je pense qu'il faut aussi les
tempérer pierre jacquemont oui alors je
suis d'accord avec le gouffre on tasse
mais il ya beaucoup de fantasmes sur le
franc cfa
notamment celui qui consisterait à lier
de sa favorite des entreprises
françaises si cela favorise l'entreprise
française vu que c'est une parité avec
l'euro ça favorise toutes les
entreprises européennes par mail à la
française mais il ya des choses qui
peuvent être faites
très rapidement et qui permettrait
ensuite d'avoir un débat sain changer de
nom le mot feront alors certes il est
encore employée dans un certain nombre
de pays
qui sont pas membres de la zone franc
mais peut-être qu'on pourrait faire
beaucoup mieux
il ya un certain nombre de propositions
il faut des baptisés il faut les deux
billy deux missiles sont 50% des
réserves de sens de ce pays auprès du
trésor français on peut très bien les
domiciliaire d'afrique ailleurs bon on
peut très bien changer le billet on peut
très bien changer le lieu où on fabrique
habibou savez que c'est fabriqué
réserves qui sont rémunérés au taux
directeur rivé c'est bien ça c'est bien
on peut très bien et l'argent versé aux
banques centrales a vraiment bien les
rémunérer auprès de la banque des
règlements internationaux sur le même
critère il ya symptômes de sauces comme
ça il faut retirer les administrateurs
français auprès des banques centrales
africaines
c'est comme un adhérent jeunes dignité
vous dire c'est aberrant même si on a
très peu d'influencé symboliquement
bloqué un certain nombre de symboles
qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait mettre
mettre sérieusement en cause y ait des
outils comptables un véritable débat
quelle monnaie auprès de quelle parité
certainement au sur un panier de
monnaies et dans quelle configuration
géographique derrière ou pas par exemple
qui est en train d r je suis pas un
économiste financier non le symbole et
sur le fond ce que j'ai vu quand même où
35 ans que je suis les réunions de
printemps de la zone franc printemps et
automne ce que toujours ce que j'ai vu
c'est des gens à la banque de france qui
travaille seul avec un bureau qui
s'appelle la zone franc n'ya pas seul
africain et qui prépare des documents
les types arrive à bercy on leur prépare
les docks les milices des finances
arrivent ils attendent de voir si le
grand chef blanc va dire va donner le
feu vert pour commencer à parler c'est
insupportable et la responsabilité des
pas de côté de la france il est deux
côtés des dirigeants africains il du
côté des ministres africains des
finances des mugs des banques centrales
il faut il faut gérer c'est vrai qu'on
dit toujours françafrique moi je me suis
intéressé à l'africa france parce que
les tipis sont bien au chaud j'ai connu
un seul ministre l'économie des finances
ivoirien qui maintenant est décédé qui
m'a dit je suis arrivé à bercy il y
avait la réunion qui démarrait du trésor
et tout le monde me disait moi j'ai hâte
de commencer aux médias non faut
attendre monsieur le ministre est au lit
mais pourquoi faut je peux pas commencer
à parler
on lui a dit ah bah nouveaux conseillers
français sont pas arrivés parce que
c'était l'esprit ça a duré trop
longtemps alors je ne sais pas sur le
fond le truc mais c'était incroyable
illustrateur funds etc
les tipis viennent en villégiature mais
c'est pas possible
responsabilité aujourd'hui des états
africains de leaders africains en
championnat me tais et non mais il est
africain
on parle toujours de la france moi qui
suis pro vieux françafrique
depuis ces messieurs afrique mais il ya
une responsabilité des états africains
dont entend papaye des dirigeants
africains
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
effectivement burkina faso et au au
sénégal il ya eu des changements par les
sociétés civiles africaines parce que
y'a voilà en charge le nouveau monde
entre guillemets ou des bourdes en vous
aurez le mot de la fin
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya eu il ya une
rupture aujourd'hui on est tous partis
prenants de cette rupture
une espèce d'excès de l' attitude
compassionnelle vis-à-vis de l'afrique
était une nouvelle qui était une autre
forme d'ailleurs donné aux colonies
paternalisme et qui n'encourageait pas
les africains à prendre en charge leur
destin et assumer leurs responsabilités
sans avoir centimes en le faisant que
nécessairement il devait tomber
immédiatement dans des règlements de
comptes ou non des vendettas etc
et de ce point de vue effectivement le
franc cfa concentre toutes les
symboliques possible mais leur hausse
est bien trop une monnaie commune à
l'échelon d'une grande région du monde
ça soit aussi une politique commune ça
crée des synergies pour eux d'aider les
politiques économiques en toile de lin a
raison il faut africanisé le franc cfa
il faut le des colonisés et ça peut
participer de quelque chose qui est au
coeur de notre débat mais qui est
largement la responsabilité des
africains c'est à dire la décolonisation
et comment souvenons pas les esprits par
les esprits effectivement et on est là
dans le symbole mais les symboles sont
importants merci à vous nous avoir
éclairé dans ce débat alors pour aller
plus loin je rappelle votre ouvrage
africa france antoine glaser quand les
dirigeants africains deviennent les
maîtres du jeu c'est aux éditions fayard
réédité en poche chez plurielles voilà
c'est fini mais pas de panique vous
pouvez voir documentaires et débats en
replay à l'envi sur notre site
publicsenat.fr n'hésitez pas à réagir et
a commenté sur notre match tag umd merci
à alexandre delrieu et à aurélie d'afas
d'avoir préparé cette émission on se
retrouve bien entendu la semaine
prochaine pour interroger notre monde en
doc très belle semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]